Julia a dynamic general purpose
programming language capable of high
performance scientific Computing with
high-level code it was created in 2012
by a gang of computer scientists who set
out to build a language with the speed
of C the dynamism of Ruby the
practicality of python that can do
statistics like R and linear algebra
like Matlab out of the box it's a
general purpose language but is most
well known for its use in numerical
analysis data visualization and machine
learning it's extremely fast because
unlike most high-level languages it uses
a just-in-time compiler to convert your
source code into machine code before
running it and unlike most dynamic
languages it has a flexible parametric
type system that means static typing is
optional by default and types can take
parameters allowing one type to
represent many different possibilities
this opens the door to the multiple
dispatch pattern where one function can
have multiple methods or implementations
based on its input parameters and the
language will determine which method to
dispatch at runtime in fact even
operators like Plus or functions that
use multiple dispatch to handle a
variety of different type common Nations
to get started install Julia then create
a file ending in JL declare a variable
by providing a name then assign a value
to it names support utf-8 encoding like
emojis or mathematical symbols it uses
symbols to represent built-in constants
like Pi allowing you to write equations
more elegantly in your code like Pearl
it's very good at string parsing and
supports multiple Expressions on a
single line resulting in tourists yet
powerful code Define a function with the
function keyword and close it with the
end keyword or shorten it to a single
line with the equal sign or because
functions are first class objects they
can be assigned to a variable or pass to
another function anonymously what's
interesting though is that by default a
function is untyped which means it
implements one method to handle all
inputs if the function is redefined but
this time with a type for the arguments
another method is added to it when this
function is called at runtime Julia will
look at the type of the arguments and
dispatch the corresponding method in
addition we can pass a type as a
parameter then use keywords like where
to perform Logic on the type itself in
this case it will assert that both types
are the same now Julia is not an
object-oriented language in the classic
sense however it does support composite
types with structs which contain
multiple fields and optional types like
any good scientific language it has very
well thought out support for arrays with
many built-in functions to initialize
and compute values over
multi-dimensional arrays it supports
asynchronous Computing with its task
model which can pause and synchronize
the execution of code like co-routines
in other languages and finally when it
comes to Big Data it can even distribute
processing to multiple memory spaces or
machines and run natively on a GPU this
has been Julia in 100 seconds if you
want to see more short videos like this
hit the like button and subscribe thanks
for watching and I will see you in the
next one